on nous met dans un truc dans une
fournaise qui est pas possible
le marathon est la marche on a peut être
considérée là j'ai l'impression que le
hors stade on est pris pour des cons
quoi clairement
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on voit tout ce que c'est une
catastrophe qui a personne dans les
tribunes que la chaleur est pas du tout
adapté qui a réélu puis 30 abondance sur
le marathon non hans hess c'est triste
[Musique]
mais l'impression de respirer de l'eau
tellement c'était humide et les plus de
90 % d'humidité
c'est ouf on y faisait vraiment très
chaud et tout de suite une sensation d'
asphyxie
quand j'essaie de me mettre vraiment
dans ma bulle et me dire allez on y va
[Musique]
j'ai tout de suite eu pas de chambre pas
de jambes ça répondait pas épuise des
sensations d'étourdissement 2
envie un peu de voix là comme si
j'allais m'évanouir ou quoi que ce soit
donc que j'ai pas dit préférer ne pas
prolonger le calvaire dans lequel
j'allais m
[Musique]
beaucoup d'abandons avec des grosses
pertes hydriques 1 parce que il y en a
conclu plus de plus de 7 litres d'eau
durant la course donc non mais on met
ses organes même exister en danger
ensuite des as et que c'est quelque
chose de très très difficile et puis
derrière les conséquences et que ben
voilà ce qu ont terminé tu le retires
vraiment plus grand coup de chapeau est
vraiment un profond respect pour eux
mais à quelle prime en la récupération
là va se jouer je ne sais pas combien de
temps ils vont pouvoir récupérer de
cette épreuve tibet but we make it mine
image fait line of sight quatre clés les
webmails matin
[Musique]
d